LYLA FUJIWARA: At
Google I/O 2017,
we announced the
Lifecycle library,
a set of libraries and guidance
for avoiding memory leaks
and solving common Android
lifecycle challenges.
The Lifecycle
library has hit 2.0.
It's also now part of Jetpack
and includes new integrations
with Databinding.
This is a tour of the Lifecycle
library's LiveData class.
LiveData is an observable
data holder class
that is also lifecycle aware.
Let's take a look at an example.
You're going to have
your UI, and then you're
also going to have this
LiveData object, which
holds some data that you
want to show on screen.
The UI observes the
LiveData object.
This is like saying the UI
wants to be notified of updates.
Therefore, when the
LiveData changes,
the UI will get
notified, and then the UI
can redraw itself
with the new data.
So in short, LiveData
makes it easy to keep
what's going on screen
in sync with the data.
OK, so here's some actual code.
LiveData objects will usually
be kept in the ViewModel class.
If you're not sure what a
ViewModel is, no worries.
Check out the video.
Let's say you're creating
an activity and ViewModel
for a user profile.
You'll have this
user LiveData object
that holds a User object.
Now, over in your
activity's onCreate,
you'll get that LiveData
from the ViewModel class.
Call observe on the LiveData.
For the first argument, you're
going to pass in the UI,
in this case the activity.
The second argument
is an "observer,"
which is just a callback.
Here you will call the
code to update the UI.
Now you can change the
LiveData by calling
either setValue or postValue.
Use setValue if you're
running on the UI thread,
and then use postValue if you're
running on a background thread.
When either setValue
or postValue is called,
the LiveData notifies
active observers.
If you're using Android
Studio 3.1 or higher,
LiveData and ViewModels
work with Databinding.
Usually you're going to go
ahead and bind your View Model
to your XML layout, which is
explained in the ViewModel
video.
Now, after associating your
ViewModel and Databinding
layout, you just need to
add this single line change
to have your LiveData
be properly observed
when bound to the XML.
You can now include references
in your XML to your ViewModel
and the LiveData stored with it.
If you use Databinding,
you're going
to no longer need to
actually manually set up
these observers.
So instead of creating
this LiveData observer code
that I showed you
before, you could
remove all that boilerplate.
Instead, the TextView's
XML references the LiveData
directly.
What makes LiveData different
from other observables
is that it is also
lifecycle aware.
This means that it understands
whether your UI is on screen,
offscreen or destroyed.
LiveData knows
about your UI state
because you passed it
when you call Observe.
OK, so here's some benefits
of LiveData's life cycle
awareness.
So let's say your
activity is not on screen,
then your LiveData doesn't
trigger useless UI updates.
If the activity or
UI gets destroyed,
then the observation connection
is cleaned up automatically
by LiveData.
Thus you'll never
accidentally trigger
an activity or fragment that
is offscreen or destroyed
to redraw itself.
This is possible in part because
of interfaces and classes
in the Lifecycle
library that are also
used by framework classes.
These classes are--
Lifecycle, which is an object
that represents an Android
lifecycle and what
state it's in;
LifecycleOwner, which is an
interface for objects that
have a lifecycle like
AppCompatActivity
or an activity fragment; and
finally, LifecycleObserver,
which is an interface for
observing a lifecycle.
OK, so LiveData is a
lifecycle observer.
It abstracts away
the need for you
to deal directly with activity
or factored lifecycle.
So those are the basics
of working with LiveData
and why it's useful.
I'm going to touch on a
few more complex usages.
Room is built to work
well with LiveData.
Room can return LiveData
objects which are automatically
notified when the database data
changes and have their data
loaded in a background thread.
This makes it easy to
have the UI update when
your database updates.
You can go ahead and learn more
about Room in the introduction
to Room video.
LiveData also provides
transformations, including
map, switchMap and a class
called MediatorLiveData
for your own custom
transformations.
Map lets you apply a function
to the output of LiveData A
and then propagate the results
downstream to LiveData B.
For example, you could use
LiveData to take a user object
and instead output a string
of the user's combined
first and last name.
SwitchMap function
transformation
is a lot like map, but
for mapping functions
that emit LiveData
instead of values.
So an example here is if
you have a bunch of users,
perhaps stored in
a Room database,
you might have a lookup
function for those users.
Using switchMap, you'd have
a LiveData for the user ID.
Whenever the ID changes,
your user lookup function
would be called with that ID.
The result LiveData now
references the newly found user
LiveData.
OK, so no matter how
many different times you
call this look up function
and get a different LiveData,
your UI only needs to observe
the result LiveData once, which
is the power of switchMap.
Now, if you want to go ahead
and make your own custom data
transformations, you
should take a look
at the MediatorLiveData class.
MediatorLiveData includes
methods to add and remove
source LiveData objects.
You could then combine
and propagate events
from all these
sources downstream.
Getting started with
LiveData is simple,
but there is a lot of
potential for experimentation
with this lifecycle
aware observable.
Hopefully this has inspired
you to build something.
And as always, the
documentation is linked.